my son walks in the room and says mama
don't worry if anybody asks me I will
lie and tell them I'm not Muslim and my
heart sank and that one's when I realize
I can't be outside of the ring anymore
it's unfortunate they know the chump is
in office but he may have been a
catalyst to kind of create this
awakening folks are saying are my rights
protected in the same way now that we
have this president who's there that
doesn't really see me as an equal
American but the same time I'm a flip
and that's also empowered folks to say
no these are my rights
you're removable I'm not despite a surge
in hate crimes and all the anti-muslim
rhetoric coming from the White House
more Muslim Americans are running for
office than ever before at least 90
Muslim American candidates are running
for office nationwide many of them are
here in Michigan Michigan is also a
swing state that some blame for putting
Donald Trump in the White House did
Trump have anything to do with you
wanting to run yeah I mean it was it was
sort of the icing on the cake for me I
was really frustrated with governments
at both the local level and the state
level and I think for the Muslim
American community in particular there
is so much to lose that the
responsibility to be engaged and to
raised voices matters a lot
I'm not running to be the first Muslim
anything I am running to be a great
governor for my state but being a Muslim
in politics comes with its challenges my
own neighbor I recall when I knocked his
door and I said Abdullah mood I'm
running for State Representative
I said I'm disgusted that you're my
neighbor and slammed the door back in my
face how does this make you feel and you
just have to tie yourself that the work
must continue you're not there yet that
this you know utopia where everyone is
treated equally is that you know a
distance away are you fighting just for
it today right now I also got you know
oh don't vote for Rashida at a polling
location
you know vote for Santa Claus write that
name down because we don't want to send
Rashida to Lansing to bomb it so you're
gonna get that backlash but I also see
such opportunity because 109 of my
colleagues on the House floor in the
Michigan House had never ever worked
with a Muslim or American Muslim the
faith is alone Islam is so misunderstood
by so many and that's why it's important
that I'm out here door knocking because
the direct human contact is important
hate crimes against Muslims has spiked
in the last two years and incidents
targeting mosques increased tenfold from
2009 to 2016 in April a video by a
Republican candidate for governor
Patrick Colbeck surfaced claiming of
Sayyad was part of a Muslim plot to
start a civilization jihad I knew that
when I jumped into this there were going
to be a lot of hateful people who
targeted their sites on me I think
division is the tool of small people and
there are a lot of small people in
leadership right now and that's largely
because because many of us have stood
out of the arena what would your message
be to people who share Patrick's kind of
sentiments so anybody that shares those
sentiments I'd say that willful
ignorance is radical and that all you
have to do is reach out to ask questions
I invite any and everyone that would
like to to come down to the city of
Dearborn and I'll take you to altar road
where our mosque neighbors are churches
I'll take you to our middle elementary
schools where our youth play amongst
each other regardless of any religion
identity ethnicity or the color of their
skin
[Music]
right now we're in Dearborn we're at
Hess in the badges house and some young
Muslim Americans are gathering to talk
about politics to have some tea and why
are we here why do you guys meet during
Rumble outs with all our schedules
collide after it's not no one has
anything to do usually get together talk
politics but are you all in politics
like inherently or how does it work
so Vita run a lot of campaigns but I've
doubled over most before awesome none of
us ever felt insecure in this nation or
in this country at the community until
9/11 a lot of us obviously a lot of our
rights were taken away as a community
the election of Trump for a lot of us
was a reminder of that and that was
nowhere that we ever wanted to be again
huh so that's what triggered a lot of us
to step up in that way 9/11 happened I
was kind of a wake-up call for all of us
the high school with tools little ease
they well not need like far right she
just used to call it Hezbollah high what
would you say is the reason why there's
Muslim Americans running out we keep
saying Muslim Americans but I think it's
also very important to note that the
amount of amazing powerful Muslim women
that have spearheaded a lot of the
changes within our community one of
those women is solid she was a state
representative in Michigan for six years
and now she's running for national
office you know we've heard there's a
lot more Muslim Americans running but it
really feels like there's also a lot
more Muslim American women who are not
just running but politically engaged you
know women tend to be reactionary you
know we tend to wait when we're need it
where many kind of get up and say I'm
gonna run for president you know and
look what we got
so I think with women it's it's we're
much more analytical waiting for that
time where it's like you know what boys
clear out the room I think it's time for
us to come and fix the gun crisis fix
the education system you had your chance
I think it's about time you give us a
chance the candidates we spoke to aren't
shying away from being Muslim Americans
they're seeing me I'm embracing being
close to me I'm embracing you Muslim
embrace to meet Arab America embracing
being a Detroiter
I don't want anybody whatever their
faith being Jewish being Muslim being
Catholic being atheist being whatever
they LGBTQ whatever it is I don't ever
want anybody to feel like they have to
hide
have you ever thought about changing
your name I'm not interested in
governing as anybody else but me and
that's the only person I can govern us
and so I am Abdul I have had a beard
since I was 19 and I pray a certain way
and I'm fully comfortable in being that
guy I like to think that in doing this I
have the opportunity to show a number of
other people young people who are
worried about this moment have to grow
up as young people with president Donald
Trump as their president see themselves
in what I'm doing
ha listen I'm American I'm just as
American as anyone else I was born and
raised here I've literally lived in this
house on Miller since I was born
our community is no longer just with one
voice our communities people that are in
their 30s in their 20s but a lot of our
parents generation not they trust us to
lead when it comes to our generation
we're afraid to say what's on our mind
that they're not that's why I want them
to take the lead so I recently hosted
the Michigan Muslim capital day in
Lansing and the hashtag that I use was
the Muslims are coming and that's
addressed right but it's also know and
truth we are coming and we are going to
be engaged like any other American and
you're gonna respect our voice like you
respect anybody else's we're a fairly
young population in America and as we
mature you'll you'll see us kind of
spread throughout various fields
including public service no longer we're
just gonna be doctors lawyers and
engineers as their parents always wanted
us to be we're gonna be journalists
we're gonna be affiliated with the arts
we're going to seek public office we're
gonna run campaigns to be field
directors and as we kind of mature
within the American culture I think
we'll just continue to rise
[Music]
you